foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
continuous bioprocessing new challenges
and opportunities for membrane
technology
this webinar is part of the fourth
annual bio processing virtual event
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
First participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find the live chat located at the right
of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window
below the presentation window and follow
the process to obtain your credits
I'll now present today's speaker Andrew
L zindy PhD Uncle chair and professor of
chemical engineering director membrane
science engineering and Technology Mast
Center the Pennsylvania Pennsylvania
State University
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Dr Sydney you may
now begin your presentation
well thank you for the introduction uh
it's really my pleasure to be able to be
here today to tell you about some of the
work that my group has been doing uh in
the area of continuous bioprocessing
with a particular focus on the
application of membrane technology for
the continuous purification of
monoclonal antibody products foreign
if you look at the current portfolio of
drugs that are provided by the
biopharmaceutical industry you see that
the best seller list is dominated by
monoclonal antibody and monoclonal
antibody related products like Fusion
proteins annual sales of monoclonal
antibodies are now greater than 100
billion dollars a year and there are
exciting New Opportunities some of you
may have studied the Press reports on
the release of monoclonal antibodies for
the treatment of Alzheimer's as well as
covid-19 these open up exciting new
avenues for the development of
Biotherapeutics
now if you look at the overview of the
manufacturing process for producing
monoclonal antibodies
um they all look generally the same
beginning with a bioreactor either
single use or stainless steel uh in the
case of antibodies typically used to
grow Chinese hamster ovary cells and
then you go through a series of steps
involving clarification primary capture
polishing and formulation
now the industry today accomplishes this
purification or a set of operations uh
in a fully batch mode that is each step
in the process is completed before the
next step is even begun so you would
grow your sales and uh they would
produce your product in the bioreactor
at the end of that process you would
clarify the entire suspension to remove
host cells and sell debris you would
then take that entire batch of material
and go through the primary capture step
and then subsequently through polishing
and formulation this typically requires
large stainless steel tanks uh the
standard bioreactor for monoclonal
antibody production is usually a 20 000
liter size reactor and it requires a
long period of time typically if you
look at the time going from the
beginning of the process to actually
having a formulated drug product it
averages about a hundred days
now this type of production process has
been recognized for many years as having
a number of shortcomings uh this is a
quote from Robert Broadway the CEO of
Amgen in an article that was published
uh in the MIT technology review just
about a decade ago and he specifically
comments that today's systems are hugely
expensive and can take months and with
more efficient processes in place
companies could not only increase
production of drugs in high demand but
they could produce medicines for rare
diseases more cost effectively
now this is particularly true or
important for some of the newer
applications of monoclonal antibodies as
I mentioned the FDA granted accelerated
approval uh for biogens therapeutic
antibody for the treatment of
Alzheimer's uh just this past summer uh
it's a monoclonal antibody that has been
shown to reduce amyloid beta plaques uh
the cost when it was introduced was
fifty six thousand dollars per patient
per year if you look at the number of
people in the United States alone Who
currently live with Alzheimer's this has
a total Market potential of 350 billion
dollars a year which is more than 40
percent of the total medical Medicare
expenditures in the United States uh
this is clearly not sustainable and
we've seen uh the additional challenges
on the Health Care System uh that have
occurred because of covid-19 over the
past two years
something needs to be done to reduce the
cost of production of these types of
Therapeutics if they are ultimately
going to achieve the clinical benefits
that we would ideally like to see
now there are a number of strategies
that can be followed to improve the cost
of manufacturing but one of these that
has been identified specifically by the
FDA is continuous Manufacturing
um as Janet Woodcock specifically noted
she was at the time associate director
of the FDA there have been very little
change in manufacturing platforms and it
was her hypothesis back in 2011 uh that
there would over the next 25 years be an
abandonment of those practices in favor
of cleaner more flexible and more
efficient continuous manufacturing
processes
now why won't one be interested in
continuous bioprocessing well if you
think about the switch from batch to
continuous processing you can eliminate
the whole tanks that are required in
current batch manufacturing processes if
your product moves continuously from one
unit operation to another in addition
because all of the operations are
performed at the same time the size of
the manufacturing equipment shrinks
dramatically for a continuous process
relative to that for a batch process and
thus the overall Capital cost for a
continuous process can be orders of
magnitude smaller than that for a batch
process
in addition we can get much greater
productivity because all of the
equipment is in use at all times we
don't have to wait for one operation to
finish before the next operation starts
and we can eliminate all of the
non-value-added steps that are often
required in bioprocessing of batch
systems for example the cleaning and
validation before and after each step
there can be greater flexibility for
continuous processing systems allowing
them to be used in multi-product systems
where we can have closed systems with
minimal transfers and better utilization
of the manufacturing Suite
and there's even the potential for
improved product quality typically
products that are produced in a
continuous system will have much shorter
resonance times within the process which
leads to less aggregation and less
product degradation and there's a more
uniform micro environment which leads to
better control over things like
glycosylation patterns and extent of
deamination
now my group has been very actively
involved in looking at opportunities for
the development of continuous
bioprocessing systems and I wanted to
take the time I had today to go over
three short examples
the first is on the final formulation
step by diet filtration the second is a
continuous counter current tangential
chromatography that could be used in
place of column chromatography for the
purification of monoclonal antibodies
and finally a precipitation washing
procedure that could be a low-cost
alternative to protein a for initial
monoclonal antibody capture foreign
so let me begin with the final
formulation step and then work my way
backwards in the process
today formulation of monoclonal
antibodies and in fact most protein
Therapeutics is performed using batch
diet filtration
in this case our product stream is
contained in a recycled tank in a uh in
the system and is continuously recycled
through a membrane unit that has very
high retention for the monoclonal
antibody but let's both buffer
components as well as water pass through
the membrane
in this case we continually add in a
diet filtration buffer and wash away the
previous buffer components to formulate
our monoclonal antibody product in an
appropriate buffer for storage and
delivery to the patient
now this is an inherently batch process
the new buffer which I call the diet
filtration buffer is slowly added into
the product solution
while the old buffer components are
filtered out through the membrane module
if you think about this way the process
runs our product solution begins in the
penultimate buffer and it is slowly
replaced with the new formulation buffer
and it doesn't get fully into that
formulation buffer until the very end of
the process
multiple times through the ultra
filtration module subjecting the
monoclonal antibody to multiple pump
passes which could lead to degradation
or aggregation and loss of quality in
our antibody product
now how might we consider switching this
to a continuous process
but in its simplest form diet filtration
is nothing more than a dilution
combined with a concentration step
in
instantly so the volume of our product
solution doesn't change with time
but in a continuous process we could
think about doing this sequentially
where we would take our antibody feed
dilute it with a buffer and then
reconcentrated in a membrane module
which would remove the old buffer
components and leave our antibody in the
desired new buffer
now although this works in principle it
does not work in practice because in
order to get a thousand fold reduction
in the concentration of any of the
buffer components that are currently
present with the monoclonal antibody
product
you would need to use a diet filtration
buffer flow rate that was 999 times
larger than the flow rate of your
antibody product that's completely
impractical first it would require way
more buffer than one could ever utilize
as part of a purification process and
secondly
um
reconcentrating the antibody by a factor
of a thousand in a single pass through a
membrane module is currently well beyond
the technology of even the best membrane
modules that are available commercially
so instead what we have decided to do is
to look at a counter current stage die
filtration process that accomplishes the
same thing that is we do our diet
filtration continuously in a single path
through the membrane unit but it
functions in a practical way with
relatively low flow rates of buffer and
relatively low requirements for the
concentration step by taking advantage
of counter current staging
now this is the diagram of the process
in order to see the counter current
staging it's helpful to look at the flow
rate of the diet filtration buffer and
the monoclonal antibody separately so
the diet filtration buffer is added to
the first module on the left
and we then take the permeate from that
module put it into the second module and
then into the third module and thus if
we were to follow the flow of the diet
filtration buffer it goes from left to
right from module 1 2 to 3.
in contrast if we look at the monoclonal
antibody
it's actually added into the third
module the one that's furthest to the
right and the retentate from that module
is cycled back to the second module and
then the retentate that exits the second
module is cycled back to the first
module that's the antibody is moving
from right to left counter current to
the direction of the disulfrasion buffer
this allows us to collect the purified
or Diet filtered antibody product out of
the very first module right where it is
contacted with the diet filtration
buffer
each of the modules allows us to remove
some of the penultimate buffer
components eventually getting to the
desired degree of diet filtration but we
effectively reuse the buffer so that our
overall buffer requirements are kept
quite well
for those of you with a chemical
engineering background this is in many
ways analogous to the operation of mixer
settler systems for staged extraction
where the settler has been replaced by
the membrane module and the mixing
actually occurs in small static mixers
that we use to mix the diet filtration
buffer and the monoclonal antibody
product right at the exit to each of the
membrane modules
the counter current staging as I
mentioned allows us to get high
performance with relatively little
buffer flow in the system
so we use the model system to
demonstrate the capability of this
device in this case we used vitamin B12
as a model in Purity because it's very
easy to detect by a color or metric
assay We performed our diet filtration
with an IGG or antibody feed at a
concentration of 120 grams per liter
that contain 2 800 milligrams per liter
of vitamin B12 and these are the results
for the vitamin B12 concentration in the
diet filtered product that leaves this
three-stage diet filtration process
as you can see the concentration of
vitamin B12 is perfectly stable over a
24-hour process we ran this continuously
without any uh cleaning or regeneration
of the membrane module
the vitamin B12 leaving this system is
about a thousand folds smaller than the
vitamin B12 concentration in the feed
that is we're removing 99.9 percent of
the vitamin B12 in a single pass through
the three-stage system and this actually
requires about 30 percent less buffer
than traditional batch diet filtration
processes for formulation of a
monoclonal antibody product
now we can actually look at the
optimization of this type of counter
current stage die filtration it's really
a trade-off between the number of stages
and the amount of diet filtration buffer
that we use in the process
and what I've shown here is the
predicted values of the fold removal
that is how much of an impurity can we
remove
as a function of the flow rate ratio on
the x-axis for a single stage system n
equals one a two-stage system n equals
two and then a three and a four stage
system a typical Target in a bio process
might be a thousand fold removal of an
impurity that was present in the system
or a buffer component as you can see we
can do this in a three-stage system
using a flow rate ratio of just about
10. if we tried to do this in a
two-stage system we would require about
a 35-fold flow rate Ratio or a factor of
three and a half more buffer and if we
try to do it in a single stage system
the buffer requirements would be so
large that they're well off this axis uh
the symbols on this platter experimental
data we had both a tooth stage and a
three-stage system that we built in our
lab and you can see that the data are an
excellent agreement with the model
calculations allowing us to use this
type of analysis to optimize the design
of a counter current stage diet
filtration process based on the cost of
the membrane modules which is
proportional to the number of stages the
cost of the buffer which is of course
proportional uh to the buffer flow rate
and the targeted degree of impurity
removal
I want to switch gears and talk about
another exam
under current tangential chromatography
most of you are probably familiar with
protein a chromatography which is used
for the purification of essentially all
monoclonal antibody products
in this case one takes a protein a
ligand
covalently links it to the pore
structure of a chromatography resin and
then packs that into a cow
you can then pump your antibody solution
through that column bind the antibody to
the protein a ligand wash away
impurities change the buffer conditions
to elute the product strip away any
residual impurities and then regenerate
the column for a subsequent cycle again
this is an inherently batch process you
can't start the washing step until
you've bound all your product and you
can't start the illusion step until
you've washed away all the impurities
now there have been a number of attempts
to make what I would consider to be
pseudo-continuous chromatography
processes using multiple columns that
are configured so that you switch
between one column and another
I'm not going to discuss those but I'm
going to instead focus on an alternative
approach which we have referred to as
tangential flow chromatography
in this case we take the chromatography
resin which are these large bluish
particles we use protein a ligands that
are bound to those resins but now
instead of packing the resin in a column
we actually use it in the form of a
flowing flurry and we flow that slurry
over a membrane that allows us to filter
out the host cell proteins while
retaining the large resin particles that
have bound the monoclonal antibody
product
in principle we could use the exact same
approach
for recovering the antibody in this case
we would switch the buffer
the antibody would come off of the
chromatography resin particles it could
be filtered through the membrane
and we would recover the purified and
eluded antibody product in the permeate
while the Reds and particles are
retained by the membrane and recycled
back in the system
thus this new process of continuous
countercurrent tangential chromatography
or cctc
exploits the benefits of affinity
binding in a chromatography step
but it uses counter current staging to
improve the performance of The Binding
washing and illusion steps to reduce the
amount of buffer and enhance the yield
of our antibody product
all of the operations are performed on
this flowing slurry
and we use a combination of hollow fiber
membrane modules and static mixers for
the fluid and resin management that is
to give sufficient residence time for
binding and then to be able to remove
host cell proteins in the washing step
in our monoclonal antibody product in
the illusion step
this really functions as essentially a
conveyor belt are resin particles go
through the binding step then the wash
step then the illusion steps stripping
and equilibration here we've shown
actually two wash steps at different uh
conductivities
the resins just cycle continuously
through and then back to the
meanwhile in The Binding and wash steps
any wholesale proteins that go through
the membrane are collected as waste in
the illusion step we of course collect
our purified product where that product
could then be immediately taken to
subsequent steps in the downstream
process
this is truly continuous and steady
state all the resin is in use at all
times with some of the resin in The
Binding step and some in wash some in
illusion and some in stripping and
equilibration
and it's truly its steady state that is
we continuously pull off product in the
illusion step at a constant flow rate
and a constant product constant
now as I mentioned each stage in the
chromatography system is really just a
combination of a static mixer and a
hollow fiber membrane module the static
mixer provides the residence time for
binding and desorption
the hollow fiber membrane module allows
us to completely separate the resin from
the fluid phase allowing us to recover
the resin particles and wash away all of
the host cell proteins
this is a typical diagram of our picture
of what the system might look like we
have a series of these Hollow fiber
membrane modules and static mixers
they're put in a series Arrangement so
that we can do counter current staging
in a way that is very similar to the
staging that I talked about in the die
filtration process
that's shown here in a two-stage system
where each stage has a static mixer and
a hollow fiber membrane module
the resin slurry comes into this system
on the left goes through the static
mixer the Hilo fiber membrane module
it's retained and then it goes into
stage two
in contrast in this case for the
illusion step the illusion buffer is
added into stage two and the permeate
from stage two is recycled back to stage
one and that allows us to collect the
product from that stage
the staging is absolutely essential to
getting high yield of the product this
is a comparison of experimental data and
model calculations for uh the
performance of the illusion step using a
flow rate of the Aleutian buffer to the
slurry flow rate of three if we did this
in a single stage system we could only
recover about 78 percent of 77 percent
of the product uh because too much of
the product would stay with the flowing
slurry as we go up to Stu state two
stages we can get to 94 three stages we
can get to 98 and you could even drive
this higher if you were to add more
stages
this is even more important in the
washing step where we're trying to get
very very high levels of impurity
removal single stage washing would
require simply unacceptable amounts of
wash buffer but as we go to two three or
even four stages we can get
10 000 fold reductions in the impurity
concentrations while still maintaining
reasonable levels of buffer uh usage for
this type of chromatography process
now in order to make this work we need
to be able to operate the membrane units
continuously for an extended period of
time in order to do this we operate
these membrane units below what's known
as they are critical filtrate flux this
is typical data from a flux stepping
experiment that's used to evaluate the
critical flux we stepwise increase the
flux and look at what happens to the
transmembrane pressure at low values of
the flux the pressure remains quite
stable but as we increase the flux we
eventually get to a point where the
pressure first becomes unstable and this
is what we Define as the critical flux
and we choose to operate usually about
10 to 20 percent below that critical
flux to avoid membrane fouling in the
system
this is typical data for the pressure
profile and The Binding step operated
below the critical flux this was for an
eight-hour process you can see the
pressure remains completely stable
there's no fouling of the membrane
modules in addition the maximum pressure
is only about 2 PSI in contrast to the
100 plus PSI that's used in column
chromatography this makes it very easy
to develop fully disposable systems in
which the entire flow path is just
plastic tubing without any of the
stainless steel piping that might be
required for large pressure operation
as I mentioned this process is
continuous this is the profile for the
eluded product uh we start with an
initial equilibration of the system
where we're not generating any product
uh just before the two hour point we add
in our monoclonal antibody feed and you
can see this is the absorbance profile
coming off of the illusion stage it is
completely steady state it's a short
residence time process meaning that
there's less opportunity for protein
degradation or aggregation and it allows
us to use this as part of a fully
continuous
Downstream process
uh this is a comparison of the
performance of of the system used for uh
antibody purification specifically
looking at the host cell protein level
as well as the aggregate concentration
uh in our clarified Harvest for this
particular material feed stream we had
54 000 parts per million of host cell
proteins as determined by an Elisa we
were able to reduce that to 210 parts
per million in our cctc system which is
actually three-fold better than what one
can do uh in a pack column operating
under the same conditions we think that
was because we actually designed a
better washing process for our
continuous process and we actually had
slightly lower levels of aggregate uh
more significantly the productivity of
this continuous process was more than
four times greater than that for a
column system because all of the resin
was in use at all times
there are numerous advantages of this
system there's no columns and packing
thus there's reduced labor costs and
reduced validation costs it's truly
continuous operation allowing us to get
higher productivity and as I mentioned
before it's a fully disposable flow path
in addition there are a number of things
we can take advantage of in this type of
continuous chromatography system which
would be impossible in a packed column
right now Pat Collins typically use
particles that are at their smallest
about 45 microns in diameter and the
reason for this is that if you go with
any smaller particles the pressure drop
through the column becomes exorbitantly
high and can actually cause damage to
the chromatography particles
this constraint though of pressure drop
is completely eliminated when we use a
flowing slurry because the pressure drop
for pumping a slurry of 45 Micron sized
particles is basically identical to that
for using 25 micron parts
and so we worked with purolai 2 is one
of the manufacturers of protein a resins
and designed a smaller prototype
particle resin that could still be used
for protein a chromatography these have
an average particle size of just about
20 to 25 microns because of the smaller
particle size it is much shorter time
required for the antibody to diffuse
into the center of the particles to bind
to the protein a ligands and thus we
could get much shorter resonance times
in our binding step compared to what one
would achieve uh with 45 Micron
particles and this smaller revenance
time allows us to develop a higher
productivity uh continuous
chromatography system in this case we
were comparing a column with 45 Micron
particles to our continuous system with
45 Micron particles and then our
continuous system with 25 micron
particles
they all provided very similar yields of
antibody and similar reduction in
wholesale proteins but the big
difference is in the productivity and
the productivity of the continuous
chromatography system using the 25
micron particles is twice that in our
continuous system with 45 Micron
particles and about 12 times larger than
that in the column
note that we could not operate our
column with 25 micron particles because
the pressure drop required to flow
through that column would have actually
crushed the particles and made it
impossible to do the chromatography
um I do need to acknowledge some of the
collaborators on the continuous
chromatography system uh this technology
is being developed by chromatan
corporation uh olec shinkaj is the CEO
and president uh we obtain funding from
the NIH the FDA and the Ben Franklin
technology partners and collaborated as
you can see with a number of companies
in particular Eli Lilly Burke regeneron
Fujifilm diaspin and Spectrum Labs in
addition to Pure light uh and as a point
of disclosure I currently serve on the
board of directors for chromatin
uh in the time that I have remaining I
want to go through one more example uh
which is work that my lab is currently
actively pursuing in looking at a
precipitation process as a low-cost
alternative to protein a chromatography
uh for initial product capture
now precipitation has been used in the
past for the purification of plasma
proteins and one of the reasons that it
works well for commercial purification
of plasma proteins is that the proteins
are present at very high concentrations
within plasma now the original
monoclonal antibody processes had
relatively low tiders of antibodies
making precipitation largely impractical
but today it is very possible to get
antibody processes that give titers of
10 grams per liter or higher coming out
of the bioreactor which is even larger
than the IGG concentration that is
present in plasma and as we've been
looking at the design of targeted
precipitation processes that could
potentially be used for initial
clarification as well or initial
purification as well as concentration of
monoclonal antibodies directly after
clarification leaving a bioreactor
system
foreign
most of the work that we've done has
been using zinc zinc uh as a selective
precipitator for monoclonal antibodies
uh these actually couple with the
histidine residues in antibodies to form
transiently or reversibly cross-linked
species that will ultimately precipitate
and we can reduce the amount of zinc
that we need for this process by
combining the zinc with polyethylene
glycol which is a volume exclusion agent
that essentially pushes the antibodies
closer together and encourages their
precipitation
the way we do this in practice is to use
a continuous tubular precipitation
reactor uh you bet employee static
mixers to obtain very uniform residence
time we take our harvested and clarified
cell culture fluid mix it with zinc in
the first reactor to nucleate
precipitate we then add polyethylene
glycol to enhance the precipitation and
then what comes out of this will be
precipitated IGG with all of the host
cells proteins remaining in solution so
that they can simply be filtered away
from the monoclonal antibody product
the total residence time in this system
is less than about 45 seconds
allowing us to very quickly get our
precipitated protein which can then be
purified by a membrane filtration step
uh this is the yield of monoclonal
antibody after the zinc chloride and Peg
precipitation
you can see that we get
about 98 yield
continuously over 24 hours of operation
the way we would run this process as a
full process
is we would do our two-stage
precipitation we would then dewater in a
membrane unit which would concentrate
the precipitate as well as removing some
of the host cell proteins
we would then go through a staged
washing procedure very similar to The
Counter current staging that I described
in both the formulation process for Gaia
filtration as well as the counter
current tangential chromatography
we would then redissolve the antibody by
adjusting the pH using a glycine buffer
and this would also drop the pH which
would allow us to go directly into a
continuous virus and activation step and
then into the rest of the down
s um this is early work showing the size
exclusion chromatograph of the purified
monoclonal antibody product you can see
the antibody is the large Peak that's
present in the SEC
there is a small amount of host cell
protein which are still present in the
system we think these low molecular
waste species could still be removed but
it would require increasing or enhancing
the washing step that we're using for
the purification of the precipitated
protein
well let me wrap up here uh I hope I've
been able to show you how one can
rethink about the use of or the
development of processes
for continuous purification of
monoclonal antibodies as well as other
uh biopharmaceutical products uh
continuous processing is a strategy has
the potential to dramatically reduce the
cost and improve the flexibility of
biomanufacturing processes
it does require A New Perspective on the
downstream process uh and much of this
provides New Opportunities uh for the
design and development of Novel membrane
systems
the idea of using counter current
contacting or staging is a general
approach that can allow us to convert
batch membrane systems into continuous
membrane systems and I've given you
three examples one for formulation using
a counter current stage diet filtration
one for purification using counter
current tangential chromatography system
and one for antibody capture
based on precipitation in combination
with a membrane filtration step
finally I need to acknowledge The
Graduate students in my group who
actually did all the hard work on the
projects that I described Chris Yale and
Mario Jabra led the efforts on the
continuous countercurrent diet
filtration system uh Chris finished up
this summer and is now at spark
therapeutic I'm Maria Jabra is working
at sanofi Zhao Lee led the work on the
continuous precipitation and is now at
Merck uh the precipitation Studies have
been done in collaboration uh with Todd
prevician and his group at RPI and we've
received funding from the American
Chemical Society pharmaceutical
Roundtable the National Science
Foundation membrane science engineering
and Technology Center which is part of
their industry University Cooperative
Research Center Program uh and an NSF
goalie award that Todd prabitsian and I
were the co-pis on that allowed us to
get the precipitation studies started
uh with that I will stop and I will be
more than happy to answer any questions
that you might have
thank you Dr Sydney for your informative
presentation
we will now start the Q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
let's get started
first question is did you check another
ion for Selective precipitation
uh that's a great question and and there
there would be other divalent cations
that can could be used uh as an
alternative to zinc chloride uh there's
some literature uh on the use of calcium
that has shown uh reasonable performance
uh what we have found is that the best
precipitation in our lab has been
obtained uh using the zinc chloride
system uh zinc is also well established
as a precipitating agent uh in the
production of insulin and so we have
focused most of our efforts on looking
at the zinc uh polyethylene glycol
system but but the technology would not
be limited to that as as a precipitating
agent
well thank you Dr Sydney do you have any
final comments for our audience
no I I hope you found the webinar useful
um please don't hesitate to email me if
you think of a question afterwards uh
and I would be happy to follow up and I
hope you enjoy uh the rest of the bio
processing event
well thank you again Dr Sydney for your
time today and your important research
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
April 6th of 2024. lab Roots will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time goodbye